he has this conch he goes
and then he [__] takes off his pants
gets butt naked and he just does a
beautiful dive like that and he just
jumps in the water
[Music]
have you guys ever stayed at a resort in
Habbo no yes never you have what's it
like how did it go uh great anyone die
no no not that I know of I've been a
Cancun I just don't drink the water oh
be careful yeah I've been to Tulu yeah
I've been to Tulum too so but the Cabo
San Lucas is on the west side right yeah
I I've been to Cabo it was pretty good
but did you like it and again yeah not
drinking the water is like one thing but
now there's something else you gotta
look out for what is it cartel
not this time poisonous not this year
there's a California couple they were
staying at a Cabo Resort
and then they were starting to feel sick
they thought they either had food
poisoning or they thought they drank the
water so they went to the hospital to
check it out and then the hospital
couldn't figure out what it was they
went back to their room and they died
and a couple days later they died in
their sleep oh my God what the [__]
dysentery
um
fentanyl no it's actually something that
could happen anywhere but why is it
happening E coli no it's not equal is it
anywhere it could technically happen
right here but what diabetes is there
something terrible no I think it was
diabetes actually I read this article
it happens everywhere endlessly diabetes
[__] so what happened is police believe
that they were experiencing carbon
monoxide poisoning no somebody was
leaking exhaust fuel into the [__] AC
vent somehow there was carbon monoxide
entering the room they haven't
determined how that happened yet but
that's not the first time that's
happened because people people commit
suicide like that you know close the
garage door leave the car on right in
the hotel the hotel room so was it I
mean it had to live in other rooms
though too right because if it was like
a filtration system based on the photo
it it looks like it's a hotel room
that's like in its own little Bungalow
thing interesting so it doesn't look
like it's not like a bunch of rooms in a
row it's like in its own what if there's
a parking garage underneath that they
share air vents with and then it's been
going in cartels
oh you think it's a cartel hit huh do
you think it's a cartel hit is that what
you're saying no it's a car Hotel it's a
cartel oh wow God damn so that's what
they meant the whole time no like you
said underground what if there's cartels
underground trying to you know transfer
drugs
and the car are smoke exhausts through
the hotel room can you smell the carpet
that's the part that's the part that's
crazy is like the here's the symptoms of
like let's say there's common carbon
monoxide happening here this is how we
would feel okay all right headache
dizziness weakness upset stomach okay
vomiting chest pain and confusion so it
could be so many other things and they
always say it is very flu-like or it
says you could die before any single
symptom even occurs really but that's
why you need those monitors right yeah
the things are in the corners right
carbon monoxide that's why they don't
[__] around you have carbon monoxide
monitors they won't shut the [__] up so
I had to pull them off the [__] wait
like a smoke detector yeah it's like a
smoke detox it's a different one it's a
different one it's like a little box and
then it runs out of battery all the time
and it goes beep yeah it goes like that
so it's like [__] thing and I took it
off [__] thing I have one but I I
don't have it on either
[__] gangsters we should probably
keep the windows open yeah it's crazy
because like uh there was a couple that
died in Florida at the Sandals Resort
same thing there was a there were there
were tourists that died in November in
Mexico City same exact thing yeah why
Resort why are they why are they
happening like that I don't know
I don't know like where is it coming
from is it like from
well because the the the gas is not
carbon monoxide when you have a stove
right that's something else I mean
that's the expert what was that yeah I
think yeah it's what he said propane or
methane I think it's methane gas propane
methane butane I have no idea
[Laughter]
diabetes the chemical compound all three
of those you cook with butane methane
[__] propane that that gas that comes
out of the stove if it like filled up
the air of the room is it fatal or is it
just like flammable is the risk I
actually have no idea
what is it I'm a personal trainer bro
like what are you talking about
this house because it's fanny packs
scraped around the the stove thing hey
dude
tell your version into Suman who doesn't
know anything before we mess it up go
ahead
I we woke up it was like 6 a.m the house
started smelling like uh carbon not
carbon monoxide smell like gas okay and
we couldn't figure it we couldn't figure
I'm nervous now I couldn't figure out
where it was coming from and we were
checking everything but apparently the
stove was turning on and the pilot was
out it's because it's fanny packs
scraped the the knot when he walked it
brushed it and then the knob went from
zero to five
yeah level five yeah yeah you know how
there's hot mid low mid hot and then the
flame is full full power that's five
yeah so apparently the uh the knob was
like faulty or something and I had
nothing to do with it no fanny pack
related instances his story is that he
doesn't know how it got turned on yeah
Joe's story is at his fanny pack brushed
it it's his family yeah tell you
something stupid the first thing I do
like Mr Rogers when I come home I take
this bad boy off because I don't want
you know this is my work fanny pack this
is my outdoor fanny pack when I go home
I don't have a fanny pack he's got
yeah what if it was like a quick I need
to go out and that the kind fatty bag is
pretty big man
I keep a lot of stuff
I know for a fact that's not the first
thing you do because you don't have a
coat hanger where you open up the door
you put it up there like Mr Rogers and
[__] I do this I go
all right I'm just gonna just relax dude
I like that Joe notes for a fact
he doesn't you do yeah when you as soon
as you open the door do you unfanny pack
yourself it's on my shoulders it's a key
holder you're doing the Gen Z style it's
a key holders
how often do you put it on your hip the
fanny pack never do you think that's
like kind of [__] made or what would
you say oh no it's just it's just it's
too much it's like everywhere
you know you just want to shoulder if
you need to grab something you know oh
it is like a football kind of you know
yeah
do you always have a gun in your fanny
pack taser gun oh okay taser oh ties
yeah I use taser gun with nine
millimeter rounds no
probably in the truck but it's a tizzy
gun that shoots oh how do you get one of
those you just buy them yeah yeah you
got one clean Colleen just bought a
taser yeah Teemu you could go to Sunny
alley sunny I got everything my
[__] got the taste guns in the
you could buy tadpoles there too yeah
you can buy what tadpoles
really they have tadpole yeah oh and
then the little red ear slider turtle
dude and then if you go to the specific
Street like Maine you see a guy in a
truck selling dog in his bed yeah or
like rabbits yeah dogs yeah and then
they'll be like little birds and
parakeets Hustlers oh you know what's
sad is that because smack has such a
soft spot for bunnies uh she would pass
them all all the time because our studio
is right next to where they sell the
bunnies on there will she hoard them no
she was like she felt so bad because
they're they're in bad conditions like
they're not supposed to be crammed up
like that and then uh she like called I
think like one of the animal police or
like Peter or some [__] was like Hey
like do you guys ever do anything about
this and then they were like no we don't
do anything about that whoa because they
were just like there's nothing you can
do because it's like an endless cycle
huh they literally said there's zero you
can do and they've never once tried most
of them are uh feeder rabbits too like
they die real quick yeah they buy them
for like weird like purposes that was
kind of like our homeless situation
Glendora we would start calling the cops
and then because one guy I had a guy
that he was eating a Subway sandwich on
my front yard and he said he worked for
the FBI and then rocked those guys
and then he wrote off on his [__]
road bike and then we had another lady
that was a [__] zombie we got people
pooping on my lawn and they're just like
people put on your line up yeah it was
in your dog and then they're like you
just can't there's nothing we can do I
was like oh [__] yeah man I'm like
thanks guys yeah appreciate it but could
you get in trouble if you oh yeah
[Laughter]
dragon's body up to the street most of
the time there's more trouble than like
if you try to deal with yourself like
even the animal situation on Santee
Alley if you tried to like tell him off
cops would be like you're an idiot for
that like leave him alone you're making
more problems for yourself like what if
they get mad at you so citizens arrest
is not a real thing
do this and and if you think it's that
bad here like in other countries messing
with people is even worse and we had uh
poking heads over the wall all the time
what do you say peekaboo yeah like on
our Nest would always go off and you
would just use someone's head go like
this oh so we end up buying is um you
know those like spiky strips for Birds
yeah so I line the entire wall of the
outside and I just found out I think
like last week or two weeks ago that if
a human being gets hurt on it they can
technically sue your house yeah because
it's booby trap yeah but I was out of
movies yeah
if you can reasonably prove in court
that you didn't mean it just be like I'm
tired of these birds [__] on my wall
you'd have to like literally plant bird
[__] everywhere like you just have to
prove that it wasn't for the use you
need it you need a bird [__] guy I got a
bird [__] guy just buy a bunny put them
on top of the wall and take a picture of
it I feel like when you're when you grow
up in La though you just have this like
oh homeless people they're gonna [__]
steal from me and like they're mean or
whatever but then like when I'm in
Hawaii now my feeling of like homeless
people have completely changed because
I'll just be like walking on Waikiki
like at night and it's like everyone's
nice they don't bother you they don't
Panhandle right and there's one bum he
was like
um you know like that one walls Yeah by
uh so there's like this one
concrete structure on waihihi that goes
into like the ocean oh yes yeah so then
me and Hannah were walking
his homeless guy is like half naked
walking next to us right and it's like
Sunset it's getting dark and we're like
what the hell is he doing so he walks
past us he goes to the end and in this
fool he go like he goes he has the Conch
he has this conch he goes
and then he [__] takes off his pants
gets butt naked and he just does a
beautiful dive like that and he just
jumps in the water familiar to you yeah
but there's a lot of like he's not even
native dude he's just some like white
hippie dude that's just like probably
been in Hawaii too long with too much
drugs but like yeah I was like that was
the most interesting thing I've ever
seen man dude there's [__] kids there
too like punks yeah yeah trying to pick
fight with you really at that wall yeah
on a Saturday Friday through Sunday one
of those I see him but they don't I
don't know I mean long as you don't they
just go hey just kidding
you know like don't say that [__] to me
yeah I go there every time they're like
stop you [__] I'm just like damn
don't look at him
I know this but just don't look at them
I'm here with my wife you're the funny
guy you're the funny guy and I'm all
like hey what's up man so I never I
never had any of that so you got that
leverage though yeah that's true good
for you man I got lucky not for him
what's up you [__] off
young ass kid something I'll kick you
but you can't do it today
laughs
[Music]